she can relate to this she's president
of red renaissance and you know
uh she captured the imagination of every
republican when he had a spirited race
to be uh the next congresswoman from
maryland and replaced elijah cummings
uh kim what's your response to critical
race theory is it are you thinking
yourself
about time or why now
you know and well we know why now right
this is something that biden ran on and
something that kamala harris supports
but this is just going to further the
racial divide you know he talked about
unity he talked about healing
but when you do something like making
white teachers take anti-racist
uh therapy sessions or you know going
out and talking about whether or not
how they feel about certain students
against others it creates this divide
and it does the whole superior
verse inferior and so what that's going
to do is really hurt the students in the
long run
and for me you know miss martin she was
once a student right she was an educator
but she was once a student
and she learned just as these other
educators did so it does it doesn't even
defies logic in a way because if she
really felt that the education system
was not up to par
how would she feel that she's qualified
to be deputy deputy secretary of
education
so as i mentioned in the break uh we
grew up the evil of slavery there was
nothing uh whitewashed no pun intended
about it in fact 1976 i was in fifth or
sixth grade
and i remember roots was on and the
brutality of that if anyone wants to
watch that back nobody's saying that
slavery was at all a good thing it's a
horrific thing even the founding fathers
say this is our original sin
echoed by george w bush what are we
supposed to do now
yeah i think we're going to see
unfortunately an uptick in homeschooling
and
private education right i think there's
going to be a lot of parents that are
going to push back and say you know what
i don't want to send my kid to school
learning these types of things
right now we have kids that don't learn
much about american history but they
know all about gender studies right or
these social studies
and that's just not that important you
want your kids to be educated
right now during the covet pandemic a
lot of parents found out
whether or not their kid is great at
virtual learning or that they can
homeschool
so i think we're going to see an uptick
there it's sad to me because i think a
lot of democrats
voted for biden because they thought he
was a moderate and now he's kind of like
feeding the beast right he has to
appease
to the radical left and it's sad right
here the republicans have been terrible
of trying to legitimately get the
african-american vote donald trump did
better than anybody else mitt romney
john mccain george
w bush he doesn't pander but there's
been no strategy
and you mentioned that's why they lost
georgia what should the strategy be
to let republi to let the
african-american african-american
community know
it's the party of lincoln that wants
them part of them now
yeah i think we got to be more
persuasive you know i'm starting my my
pack red renaissance
just to basically support candidates
that really want to run in these areas
and it doesn't matter what color you are
you know there are people in these urban
areas that want to see better like i did
in baltimore city
and the republican party needs to
support these candidates so we're going
to fund them we're going to get behind
them
we're going to help them with media
whatever they need but you have to
tackle these areas
in georgia we saw if they did a little
bit more in atlanta
they might have won at least david
perdue's race uh so it's
it's critical we have to do it yeah what
they did is they tried to maximize
what they thought was their vote in
trying to get new votes
kim klasik thank you so much thank you